(upbeat music)
You have to learn to be comfortable being uncomfortable,
that's RAAM.
(bright upbeat music)
And oftentimes when we are in pain, we focus on that pain,
that's all we're thinking about.
That's why I tryna kinda park it
and not focus on that pain you know,
and thinking about the task in hand
like what have I done to you get here?
And you wanna get to that finish line, right?
So stop dwelling on the things that hurt you
and let's focus on what you need to do
to get your finish front.
(bright upbeat music)
Welcome to the podcast everybody.
My guest today is the remarkable Leah Goldstein.
Leah is an extraordinary athlete
and just an absolute force of nature.
So get this, at just 17,
she was crowned the world champion in kickboxing.
She then joins the Israeli Defense Force,
becomes Krav Maga specialist,
and the first female elite commando instructor as well
as an undercover special forces intelligence officer.
Then, in yet another dramatic life pivot,
Leah spent a decade as a professional cyclist
until a devastating crash ended her pro career
and nearly her life.
She was told she might not ever walk again
with certainly never race again.
But, undaunted Leah returned.
She reinvented herself as an ultra cyclist
and in 2021 at age 52 and entirely plant-based I might add,
became the very first woman in the 39 year history of RAAM,
the 3000 mile race across America to beat everyone.
All the men and outright win the solo division.
It's an extraordinary story.
And today's conversation hits all the sweet spots,
mindset, endurance, high-performance,
inspiration, motivation, dramatic life pivots
and overcoming seemingly insurmountable obstacles.
It's about grit, perseverance, work ethic,
and the never quit drive required to do amazing things.
But more than anything,
this is really about how important it is
for all of us to heed that inner voice
and leverage it to tap hidden reservoirs of potential
that reside within us all.
So, without further ado, this is me and Leah Goldstein.
So nice to meet you.
Thank you for doing this.
Yeah, thanks for having me, it's an honor.
So excited to talk to you.
I came across your story in the wake of the RAAM victory.
I was enthralled by what you had achieved
and I started looking more into your story
and just became progressively more and more incredulous
with all the amazing things that you've gone
and I knew immediately I wanted to get you on the show.
And I also think maybe I'm wrong about this.
But I feel like your story,
I mean, certainly you got a fair amount of media
in the wake of the RAAM victory but I feel like your story
is not nearly as well known as it should be
and I almost feel a responsibility like people need to know.
Thank you.
Well you have me here today.
Your story,
it's unbelievable, yes you know.
So I'm honored and delighted to be able
to help kind of spread the word about all the stuff
that you've done.
Thank you.
I mean, let's just start at the beginning
because we're gonna get into RAAM and all the details,
I have so many questions about that
but your background and your upbringing is fascinating.
Your mother's from China, your dad's from the Soviet Union,
he was a national boxing champion.
And just walk me through like a little bit
of the childhood story.
Oh my goodness.
Well, I mean, I was made in Israel, born in Canada,
my mother was seven months pregnant.
My father was in the military.
He docked in Vancouver, Canada
and he just saw opportunity there.
He was young, he was like 19 years old.
So he decided to move the whole family to Canada.
And your grandparents were like, had...
Talk to me about them 'cause there's a whole part.
Oh, that's a whole different I'll...
Yeah, my mother was, you know she was born in China.
And she lived there for 14 years till the communism came in
and then they escaped the communism
and they actually immigrated to Israel.
And then my father was born in the Soviet Union
and they came to Israel,
my grandmother went through the Holocaust.
So it was quite the journey you know.
You're getting to the holy land per se you know.
So yeah.
So you ended up in Canada, that's where you're born.
Correct.
Right?
Yeah.
And did you grow up as a...
I mean with your father being this boxing champion,
you know, I'm having these visions of him, you know,
some sort of karate kid situation when you were younger.
Well, I mean, like you know how most kids they watch,
in Canada it's hockey, right?
Or football or soccer.
I mean, I grew up watching boxing.
My father was just, every chance he had to watch boxing
on television that's what we did together, right?
So, and he's very animated
and he would teach me the way they stand,
the way they move, the way they pawn strikes.
So, kinda had that in me
before I even started the whole Taekwondo.
Did you go into boxing before Taekwondo
or how did that begin?
No, no, I didn't plan to go to Taekwondo.
I was bullied when I was a little kid, right?
Like every lunch hour between 12 and 12:45,
I was chased by a group of eight boys
and couldn't tell the teachers,
didn't want to tell my parents.
So, I came home one day, I got an hour of television.
I start flipping through the channels,
I'm looking for a show called Gilligan's Island, right?
And then I come across this one channel
and I see this small Asian guy fighting five, 10, 15 people,
and it was Bruce Lee.
And I said, oh my God, this guy can fight off 30 people,
I just have to fight off eight,
I have to learn whatever he's doing.
And that's how the whole Taekwondo started
then I begged my mother for lessons.
(Rich laughs)
You are your father's daughter, right?
Yeah.
So he's probably thrilled.
Not so much at that time, you know what I mean?
'Cause he knows like the impact that boxing can have.
You get a lot of hits to the head and stuff.
So, when the TaeKwonDo transitioned to kickboxing,
it took him a bit to get used to that idea, right?
Right, 'cause it was non-traditional compared
to his notion of combat sports.
Right, yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
But TaeKwonDo first, but from what I understand,
I mean, you pick this up pretty quickly.
The Taekwondo just came natural to me.
And I think because I was very athletic as a child,
I was always riding my bike or running or doing whatnot.
So I excelled fast by the time I was 12 years old,
I was a junior national champion.
And at 13 I just didn't feel challenged anymore
and that's when I transitioned into kickboxing,
a Black belt suggested, you know you're more of a kickboxer
so then there was one kickboxing studio, like kind of
in skid row area of Vancouver called Hasting Street.
And I remember going to that studio
and then I just felt at home.
Why didn't you stick with TaeKwonDo?
I mean, you had such amazing success immediately.
Because it's very traditional, right?
Like I got like red carded a lot for too much contact,
and I was a martial artist that stood like a boxer.
So you can imagine a 12 year old girl
that sounds like a boxer, right, you know.
So like I said, TaeKwonDo is more traditional,
karate is more traditional, right?
More forms and more beauty and not as realistic
to real street fighting as boxing or kickboxing,
Or more cage fighting or whatnot you know.
But I just felt at home in that kickboxing studio
and the skill just came really natural to me.
So, walk me through your progression as a kickboxer.
Well, it was most fun.
Well I was a second degree black belt
and I remember going into the studio, I had a big head,
you know 'cause I knew I was good.
I mean I barely got through the door.
I was so, I'm on myself, right?
Then the kickboxing coach comes up to me
and he goes, you know, can I help you?
And I said,
I wanna try this kickboxing 'cause I was a black belt not,
don't feel challenged.
So he just felt that I,
he wanted to teach me a lesson basically.
So he puts me into a boxing ring,
remember I'm second degree black belt.
He brings him the small little skinny kid
about half my size and I think, damn I'm gonna kill him.
But I didn't know it was his most skilled kickboxer, right?
So we stand there, the civil match starts,
whatever he throws a jab,
then it hits me in the nose, right?
And I've never had been hit like that before
'cause Taekwondo is more traditional
and I get mad and angry and I start throwing my best moves
and nothing is making contact.
So he basically grabs me from the ring,
he tells me, go home and go and think, think about it.
'Cause he could see I was frustrated
and I was trying not to cry, you know what I mean?
I go home and I felt totally deflated, right?
And I remember trying to sneak into my house
and as soon as I opened the door,
I see my mother standing there
and I could feel a trickle of blood down my nose
and she's looking at me like what the heck happened.
And the only words that came out of my mouth was mom,
I'm gonna be a kickboxer.
Next day I went back to that studio.
Yeah, and you're 14 at this point?
I'm barely 13.
Barely 13.
Yeah, barely 13.
And the instructor,
didn't he tell you at some point early on like, listen,
you're rough but you stick with this
and you're gonna be a champion?
Oh, he gave me rules.
I mean, he said to me, you wanna do this?
He goes, no smoking, no drinking, no drugs, no friends,
no swear, train seven days a week, train twice a day.
Then he says, you do that,
17 I make you a world champion.
Those are the words that came out him.
That's an amazing thing to say to a young person.
Yeah.
And that was it but I learned at that age
like what does it take to be the best and it's 110%
so I didn't do the party thing or the friend thing
or whatever.
I didn't train, you know five days a week, twice a day,
I trained seven days a week, three times a day
'cause I was that determined.
And at 17 you indeed become world champion.
At 17 I become world champion, correct.
It's unbelievable.
What's the typical age of world championship athletes
at this point.
Mid 20s.
Mid 20, right?
Yeah, mid 20s, yeah.
So it must've been quite a thing you being
that much younger than everybody else,
you bantamweight at the time?
Correct, I was bantamweight.
I was just...
Like I said, the skill, it was what?
I remember my coach 'cause I was so slight and small,
he didn't want me to wear short sleeve shirts
'cause he didn't want people to see how skinny my arm flew.
But you know, it's a matter of how you throw the punch,
you throw the power behind it right in the way you stand
and just because of my speed and my skill,
that's why I excelled so fast in the sport.
So it had to be quite an experience to know
that you were the best in the world at such a young age.
I mean, it's not something you think about
because I'll be honest with you like-
You're very oh shacks about all of it, you know?
Well, my coach will tell you something like you know...
I mean, I was very good at what I did,
but I never, ever got complimented by my coach.
He never said, oh, this is what you're good at.
He only focus on the things that I was bad at.
Even when I won the world championship, he said,
he whispered in my ear, "You could have done better."
You know what I mean?
So, there's always one up on you, right?
So, you always gotta stay grounded no matter where you are
because when you are at the top of your game,
all it means you have to work twice as hard to stay there.
Yeah.
And what did you learn about discipline and perseverance
and meeting obstacles as a young person who is so devoted
to this specific sport discipline?
I mean, like I said earlier, I mean it was...
It taught me what it takes to be the best in this lasering
and it's 110% and it's a lot of sacrifice, right?
Like you tell a 13 year old kid
to give up all the fun things,
most would probably say no, right?
But I knew those sacrifices would,
it would pay off at the end.
Good times and friends are always gonna be around
but I think especially unique opportunities won't.
Yeah.
You seem to have a predisposition, like a deep understanding
that delayed gratification is the path, right?
Like you're able as a young person going through adolescence
and the teen years where there's a lot of temptation
to kinda do a lot of different things and get in trouble
to just be very focused on the larger goal.
Well, I mean, I knew I had to work harder
at a lot of things.
'Cause even in school, let's go back to school,
I mean, I had a learning disability.
You know I was put in a special class.
And I knew I had to work twice as hard as everybody else
but I was determined to graduate with honors and I did.
But I knew for someone like me I had to work twice as hard
even when I was a child, my left leg was growing
at a faster rate than my right leg, it's longer,
it's stronger, the foot is bigger.
And doctors told my parents
that I'd never excel in athleticism.
So when you're left with that, you know you got challenges,
but are you gonna hang on to that
or are you gonna prove to people what you can do
with what you don't have?
Right, you're the kind of person who
when somebody tells you, you can't do it,
that's just fuel for the fire, right?
Exactly.
(both laughs)
But here's the thing, you become world champion at 17
and I'm just baffled at why you didn't stick with it
and just continue to pursue it.
Because that was never my dream.
Like my dream-
It was your dream enough to be so disciplined
and focused and train so hard for it.
Well, that was...
Like boosting was a problem to a solution, right?
Or a solution to a problem I should say, right?
What I wanted to do from as young as I could remember,
from when I was seven years old
is I wanted to be James Bond.
And I knew when I graduated from high school
that I was gonna go back to Israel and I was gonna go
into the IDF, the Israel Defense Force.
And I was gonna really start my career at that point.
Where did that idea come from?
Like what's the Genesis of that dream?
Okay, well, my family as you know they're all from Israel
and going back every year as a child,
I knew that members of my family were involved
in some kind of work that were secretive
'cause there's members of my family
that I would only see maybe for an hour
once every five years or whatever.
So I knew there was something secretive there
that just intrigued me and it just felt...
And as I got older, I knew it was something in security.
And it's just something that I felt that I needed to do
that I was born to do, that I was meant to do.
And it was on my radar from,
like I said from as young as I could remember.
So you had extended family members
that were like Mossad agents or-
I'm not gonna say Mossad, they're in security,
won't say what.
Security, quote, unquote, right?
Like we can't talk about it but that's pretty romantic
and intriguing for a young person to hear like, wow,
what are they really doing?
Well yeah, it just fascinated me.
Yeah.
Like you know, my parents speak many different languages
so when my uncle, when he would come in and my mother
for example she was very close to her brothers
and she didn't want my sister and I to understand,
they would swap languages into Russian, you know?
And so I started to try and pick up as much Russian
as I could to understand the conversations
that were going on.
So, it's kinda how we were brought up too.
I mean, my parents never wanted us to say anything
on the phone or you don't, you won't...
Be careful who you make friends with,
be careful what you tell your friends.
So we had had that upbringing of everything
is kind of a secret and keep it in the family sort of thing.
Wow, so your parents,
they were associated with security in some way?
If they were they're really good at it
'cause I don't know.
You don't know.
What did they do to make a living?
Well, my father, he owned industries
like he was a machinist so he bought into companies
as he got more successful, my mom was a registered nurse.
By day.
But who knows that she did at night.
(both laughs)
Oh my God.
But you have this idea, like this is the path for me.
I'm gonna go to Israel
Oh absolutely.
And enlist in the IDF.
But because you weren't living in Israel, you didn't have...
Yeah, obviously if you're an Israeli national
and you're living in Israel, you go into the army
at a certain age for a couple of years.
Yeah, it's mandatory.
Boys do three years, girls do two years
whether you like it or not.
But you weren't under that mandatory?
No, no, that's why it's called volunteer to the army.
So I went back to...
I could because my parents are Israeli
and so I immigrated, I got my Israeli passport and you know.
Right, so you go to Israel at 18, and it's the IDF.
Correct.
Right.
And typically women do like a two year tenure
with this and men do three?
Correct, yes.
Yeah, so walk me through the process
of getting indoctrinated in the army.
So for certain people,
like the IDF is a very sophisticated organization
like they don't just pick you, they know everything
about you and where they're going to place you.
So if they see something unique that they can use,
you're gonna be isolated and put
into a different department.
And that's kind of where I was at
'cause I think they looked at my background
over I came from, I don't look Israeli, you know?
So, I could work.
I'd be very useful to do certain things,
I was very athletic, I was fearless, I learned very fast.
And you spoke some Russian.
I understood Russian.
You speak Chinese also?
No, no Chinese.
No Chinese.
I mean, they're looking at your resume,
all right world kickboxing champion,
speaks a little Russian,
is already completely bought into this.
Like there's a future here.
Oh, for sure.
They can mold you any which way you want
'cause I was also very patriotic at the same time, right?
So they've got somebody perfect.
Gung ho.
Yeah.
So what is the training like?
Like you don't go immediately
into some kind of commando special forces unit, right?
Like you do-
You go through a training process,
it's called the selection process.
So they took 350 of the soldiers that have something unique
that's kind of different from the ordinary,
citizen and let's say.
So they put us through a series of training
both physically and mentally and they keep cutting you down
for that 350, it goes down to 250, then 200, then 50
and then from there you go
into a more intensive training course.
So for me because of my background in kickboxing,
I was well with kickboxing you know.
They wanted to put me in Base 8 which was...
It was a special unit space that trains commando,
and special units from not only in Israel
but outside of Israel as well in North America,
Europe, Asia, and it's called Base 8.
And there's a unit there called Krav Maga,
I don't know if you've heard of that term before.
So, Krav Maga it's a Hebrew, Krav means fight,
Maga means hands, so lethal hand combat.
So I was in that department,
and when I was recruited into that department,
after going through a series of tests,
I was one of the first female instructors
to train the commando.
So how long between you enlisting
and you becoming a Krav Maga instructor?
Six months of intense, yeah.
Oh wow.
Well, I thought maybe like two years or something.
No, no, no.
But it's like intense, like they don't let you go anywhere.
Like I wasn't released to go home I think in that period,
probably for 24 hours.
They let me go to be a civilian
and have a little bit of fun.
So it starts out with some kind
of basic training instruction and then it pivots into more
of a special forces kind of like Seal Team situation?
Yeah, we actually skipped the basic train,
'cause basic training, every soldier must learn
how to use Uzi and M-16,
certain skills like climbing a wall, rope,
you know, women, boys, girls, whatever,
everyone has to learn that skill.
We bypassed that because we went through
a testing kind of period for a week to see what we can do.
And the second excelled like basic training program
and then it goes into another form of training
that's even more intense.
So are you the first female Krav Maga instructor
or one of the first?
I was the first female instructor to train the commando.
So the commando is like the Navy Seals.
Because what's unique about that, it's not just...
You don't stand there with a clipboard,
I have to do the training with them.
And so they would send me on different...
They'd ship me out to different locations in the country,
I didn't even know where I was going to
and how long I'd be for, I just knew that they'd tell me
what I need to pack and take
and then we go on special assignments
and I was part of their training to train the soldiers.
Right, and they're older I presume.
The soldiers?
The soldiers that you were training,
you're 18 at this point, right?
Yeah, I'm 18.
Well, there are some of them,
I mean, 'cause they're recruited too.
So I'm like maybe not too much older than me,
it's during the, like maybe early 20s.
Right.
Yeah.
And what is the qualitative differences
between kickboxing or Taekwondo and Krav Maga?
Well, Krav Maga it's death, right?
You learn to use your hands in a deadly way,
how to use a rock, a stick, a stone in a deadly way.
Learn how to kill somebody
so it's a little bit more intense you know.
It's more for soldiers, right?
You know in war in situations of life or death, right?
So, less about art and more about self-defense
and aggressive action when required.
Exactly.
Under duress.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so how long were you in the IDF then?
I was an instructor with the IDF
with that department for about a year.
And then I transitioned to work
with the police force shortly after that.
And during that time, I mean were you...
So you're deployed to train other commandos
but you weren't sort of deployed as a commando yourself?
No.
On secret missions and stuff like that.
I did certain missions with the military
but not as a commando, right?
I couldn't, I didn't have the physical strength
to do what they needed to do.
You know what I mean?
I mean, it's a very difficult like you know...
Like commando soldiers, I'll just give you an example.
They go through like almost two years of training
and maybe 5% will make it, it's that intense.
Like some of those guys will crack three hours
before they graduate, it's that intense.
That's our job to make them feel like nothing
and to bring them to their lowest, right?
So, I mean, I couldn't have done...
You know what I mean?
I was a trainer but to be realistic with you,
I couldn't have been a commando soldier by any means.
But it seems like you could have been a pretty good spy.
I could have been, yeah.
Maybe I was.
Maybe you are, maybe you are right now.
Maybe I am. (Leah laughs)
Yeah, no one knows, right?
No.
I mean, because you don't look typically Israeli
and you speaking English without an accent
and all those sorts of things, right?
It's interesting that they didn't position you into that.
I mean that's the James Bond dream, right?
Well, I mean, you can wanna be a spy
but it's not up to you, it's up to them.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You would seem to be a top candidate,
they didn't recruit you for that?
I'm not gonna say they didn't recruit me,
I went through a series of training.
You're gonna get cagey now.
(Leah laughs)
I think there's a lot more going on here.
Maybe.
Than you're willing to talk about.
Yeah, I guess, I mean who knows, right?
You can only speculate.
Okay so, then you transitioned into this police force.
I mean, is that...
What does that look like in terms of like how we think
about police in the United States, in North America.
It's completely different.
I mean the police and the military work together
because the crimes of Israel are very different
than the crimes that happen in North America.
You know we have to deal with terrorism,
that's our biggest threat, right?
So, I wasn't exactly in the police force.
I was in a unit called the Belush
and the Belush was a spying agency,
but I did go through like the police training,
like the academy, like again a more intense, faster kinda
to get me through there but I had so much skill
from the military that I didn't have
to do the basic training of the police academy.
Right, so it's kind of an anti-terrorism unit.
Correct.
And in that context, I mean what was the day-to-day like?
Like what are you deployed to do?
It depends everyday.
Was it intelligence or was it boots on the ground?
It was intelligence,
more internal intelligence inside the country.
It depends if we were after a terrorist,
if we're going into the territories, we are disguised a lot.
You're very isolated.
I was positioned in different parts of the country.
You can't associate with other people and...
You know, even if like say you and I worked together.
Like under aliases and stuff like that?
Yeah, exactly.
Right, so there's some James Bond in there.
Quite a bit of James Bond maybe, yeah.
And how many people were in your unit?
In the Belush there was only myself,
I was the only woman and then there was I think,
five other guys.
Yeah, and can you kind of talk about
what a typical mission might look like?
I mean we would do a lot of surveillance
if we had to capture someone, kidnapped someone or whatever,
you know to bring them into Israel from the territories,
that kind of stuff you know.
So it's-
That's pretty heavy.
It is.
You're like 19 at this point?
I'm young, yeah, I'm 20.
Wow.
(Leah laughs)
Yeah.
'cause mind you to like to get into the Belush,
like that particular unit, you need three to four years
of police experience to even be considered
and they recruited me after four months.
So that was a big jump but that was kind of what I wanted.
Like I said, you don't ask to be a spy, they come after you.
So, they watch you, they know everything about you,
they see how you are, how you act with other people.
How much you can take.
What your behavior is like when you see certain things.
So it's a process.
Yeah, so when you watch spy movies or Hollywood's version
of what kind of international espionage
and intelligence looks like, like how...
Based on your experience, like what aspects of
that are legitimate or look real and what is kind
of nonsense compared to what you've seen yourself?
Well, I mean, we don't have flying cars
or things like that, right?
Sure, but I mean like more grounded
kind of (indistinct) type.
I mean, the reality is is that you see things
that most people don't see.
I mean, you can be working with somebody today
and then tomorrow they're gone like something
so it's dangerous.
I didn't realize what exactly how dangerous it was
so I was like 30 years old.
I just started feeling scared and a bit paranoid you know.
'Cause you almost have to go in.
'Cause if you are afraid even in inkling,
then you can't do that type of job, right?
But it's that dangerous.
You know of what we're doing and the risk that we're taking.
But you don't think that way, you just have a mission
and you're expected to do it no matter what it takes
if you're that patriotic
and that's what they expect from you.
That's why it takes a unique personality
or person to be able to do that,
just to put your life on the line go, you know what?
I have a mission to do no matter what happens.
And you did that for like 10 years then?
Almost 10 years.
Yeah.
Correct.
That's gotta be challenging, right?
Especially in terms
of like maintaining relationships with people.
There is no relationship with people.
Yeah, you can't be tied to anybody, right?
I'd also be like I worked with a lot of...
My partners had wives and children.
I would be terrified if I had a child because of-
Its leverage.
Yeah, the nature of the work, you know it's worse
when something happens to your loved then it happens to you.
So, being single and independent
and my family being way way out there,
and not having anyone write me letters
or even when I was talking with my parents,
I wanted to keep it as rare as possible.
And even to leave the country is as little as possible.
For me, just from what the experience that I saw,
it kept me....
I just felt safer that way.
Yeah.
Your parents knew what you were doing on some level though.
To a degree, I think my mom knew more than my father.
Yeah, what was their perspective?
Not great, and well my mom for sure,
she was all for it, right?
But my father was afraid because he knew people that...
I mean when I came back to Canada very briefly,
we had a private conversation and he just said that,
he knew people that escaped that kind of work.
That they left because it just and I guess tried
to scare me out of it but it didn't matter
what anyone said I knew what I was gonna do
and I was gonna do it no matter what.
Yeah.
(dramatic music)
And did you feel like you were fulfilling
that James Bond dream.
To a degree, yes I messed up once.
I think I spoke when I shouldn't have.
And so, I mean I was in a process of getting recruited.
I'm not saying to what organization, you know what I mean
but it was probably the most elite.
The one that I'm thinking of.
Yeah, the one that you're thinking of right now
and it was a series of six months,
I was going through a series of mental and physical tests
and I didn't know...
I didn't ask any questions,
I just get these notices or calls,
you're gonna be at this address at this time
in Tel Aviv or in Haifa, or in Jerusalem or whatever,
you just show up and you don't say anything,
you do whatever you're supposed to do and then you leave
and you don't know if you're gonna get a call
or not gonna get a call.
And you don't know why you're being dispatched?
You kinda know why but you just don't know
what's happening or what's gonna come next.
I mean at one point I had waited a month
and then I got another notice, right?
So it's that kind of process
and then kind of at the end of that, I called my uncle.
Because I wanted to ask him what the heck is going on,
and that was a mistake.
Your uncle being part of intelligence.
Perhaps.
Okay, right.
I'm trying to just understand this.
So, basically you spoke out of school, you weren't supposed
to say anything and just by having a conversation.
Oh yeah, I mean as soon as I...
We sat down actually on a table very similar to this,
it was a picnic table outside
in a little village called Afula.
And even before I opened my mouth he just shook his head.
And then I said, okay, I just messed up.
And it was very difficult
'cause I remember this was my dream.
Because you should never broach any of this.
You don't say anything to anyone.
So, you're immediately flagged as a security risk.
I think so to a degree like can't keep your trap sharp,
you know what I mean but...
And so, but you're young and I was so excited and eager
and just want to know what was going on
and if I was gonna be recruited and I was willing
to do anything so, it was a blow, it was a hard blow for me.
It had to be kind of romantic and exciting
but also terrifying.
And I'm just curious about
what it would feel like to be in a situation
where you know you're being watched all the time.
Like that's kind of a feel oppressive,
like knowing everything that you say,
everything that you're doing is being observed and analyzed.
Well, I mean I think it's for the security.
If you choose to do that kind of work they have to know,
perhaps you're a double agent who knows,
they don't know who you are.
Like why would a Canadian girl live in a great country,
come to Israel and wanna do a work, like what the hell?
You know what I mean?
You've been planted there.
Exactly, like what?
That doesn't make any sense
and that's why I was interviewed maybe 50 times.
Like you know what's wrong with you?
You know what I mean?
So, there're suspects.
Well, I mean-
And also you're like the only woman, right?
Yeah, I mean exactly.
So what was that like?
That was tough, for sure I had my challenges,
I had to be even better than everyone else
because I was a woman 'cause if I had a bad day,
it wasn't because I had a bad day it's
because I was a woman, right?
So, you think about that pressure of always being
on top of your game having had eyes in the back of your head
and yeah, it's a lot of pressure.
What was your kind of specific skill set,
like what was your strength in that capacity?
I'm kind of like a chameleon, I can be in places not...
Being in a place to not be known or seen or whatever
and I could, good at getting information.
It's funny 'cause I'm not a super social person,
but if I need to socialize and talk to someone
in an acting scenario, I can do it,
I'm really good at it.
So that kind of stuff, I mean, a lot of times to going into,
like a good example is going into the territories
when you were going into a house
and then there's a Muslim woman there,
when they see a woman come in,
it kind of diffuses the situation,
it makes them a little bit more relaxed.
So yeah, it was just, it depends.
Yeah. I suspect you have great situational awareness.
Like you're trained to walk into a room
and notice everything and kind of be aware of
where everyone's standing
and assess everybody's motivations.
That's a big part of the training though.
Like we know, I mean when I was being trained
into the Belush, we'd go down like in Hadera
or another village and you know one
of the agents would point to different people
and count Muslim, Israeli, Russian,
what nationality, you know what I mean?
Or like me and you having a conversation,
listening to the people behind us what they're saying.
So kind of being aware.
And a lot of times when we were in the police car,
they'd purposely put the radio on really loud
'cause we always have to hear communication
and I'd put it down to no, no, no,
you have to learn to focus your energies
in different areas even being distracted, right?
Which is really hard for me.
Like if I blair on the music right now
and you and I have a conversation,
it's gonna be tough to focus, right?
And what was the physical training like?
The physical, that actually came easy to me.
'Cause I was...
I mean I-
I'm curious about how that plays into the cycling career
which we're gonna get into in a little bit.
Well remember, we didn't talk about this
but in the military I was actually introduced to the bike
by a Lieutenant from the commando.
He was the national champion in the sport of triathlon.
And he knew what I was doing, I mean to a degree.
But he always saw me training,
so when I wasn't training troops, I was training myself
through the obstacles and what we needed to be good at,
in shooting range and what not.
So he asked me to...
And I used to commute to the base on my bike.
So he says, you know let's go for a bike ride.
And I really didn't want to but I felt bad to say no
so we went on a bike ride and I was hooked,
I just like fell in love with the bike.
And then he started actually coaching me
and he got me into the sport of duathlons, right?
And I remember my first duathlon, I was a commando soldier
and I remember, you know how I warmed up for it?
You know how most people would ride or run?
My commander came with focus pads and I was punching.
You like shadow boxing to get ready for an endurance race.
So I did the duathlon, as soon as I crossed whatever line,
I didn't have chance, he basically threw my bike
in the back of the Jeep and we went back to the base.
That's how I was able to do races
with my security team coming with me.
So how did that first race go?
It was good, I actually won it.
(Leah laughs)
You are unbelievable.
I mean okay, that gets Israel.
You know I was a big fish in a small pond.
You probably had a junky bike, right?
I had a 20 pound tank, right.
The big hairdryer helmet, you know back then
and I didn't know what clipless shoes was,
I had running shoes on.
So, did some lights go on in that moment,
like this could be a cool thing for me to pursue.
Oh totally, I wanted...
Any opportunity I had for training, we went on a bike ride
and then I started to upgrade and learn about the bike.
And I actually won my Duathlon,
it wasn't because of the running I was a good runner
but not a great runner, it was because of the riding.
And it just something that I fell in love.
Yeah.
And did you become like national champion in duathlon?
Yes, I was.
(both laughs)
How long between that first race
and becoming Israeli national champion in duathlon?
Well, I remember I couldn't go to all the races
because of whatever I was doing,
I had to get special permission by-
Can't do it, I'm undercover or it's unknown.
Well, they didn't say that
but when there was like big races,
they would give me releases so on the national championship
that was roughly a year later,
that I was able to win that race.
Within a year?
Yeah, within a year.
Wow.
But then at some point you retire from the police force.
Correct.
And the sense that I got, I couldn't find a lot of detail
on this but the sense that I got was
that things were getting crazy, dangerous
and somebody in your unit was killed
and there was quite a looming threat concerning your life.
Correct, yeah.
I mean, at this point there was I think a couple
of kidnapping attempts on me.
And remember Israel is a very small country
and is hard to hide me.
'Cause you being the only woman doing what I was doing.
And there was a lot of tension in the country at the time.
And just one incident, I was working the night shift
with my partner and we saw a police cruiser parked
on the side and two officers were sleeping with their,
kinda hugging their M-16s, which you can't do,
it's very dangerous in the area that we were in.
And we went to the car and we said,
you know what are you doing but it's a different department,
so we basically left and my partner was just yelling
at them, like you guys are stupid.
45 minutes later, they were assassinated.
And all hell break loose in the country.
And the next day too, my department gets a picture
of me saying that, oh, like threats of...
That I was a target.
So they had to hide me at that point, right?
And just knowing that I couldn't go anywhere
without being fully armed or going into my car
and checking underneath, over, whatever.
Even starting my car was...
My heart would start to beat whatever,
they rigged or do you know.
So, I started to become paranoid and afraid
and so I said, I need to transition.
Honestly, the only thing that really made me feel alive
and the only thing I wanted to do at
that time was be a pro racer.
'Cause I felt like I was good enough to do it,
I was winning races since I was, winning races against men.
Remember I'm in a very small country not really knowing
what real competition is.
But time's up in terms of your safety
and you've gotta pull the escape hatch.
Well, yeah, they couldn't hide,
where are they gonna hide me?
I mean I was transferred now into the headquarters
to train high officials like officers and whatnot.
But I felt like I was a trainer and that's not what I was...
What I had signed up for.
I wanted to work the field but...
So I basically, to make a long story short,
I made a deal with them to work on assignment
if needed outside of the country which allowed me
to come back to North America
and then I could train full-time as a cyclist.
So, what year was that?
Oh my goodness!
It would be in the '80s, late '80s.
Late '80s, right.
And you're like 30 at the time?
I'm 30, yeah.
So you moved back to Canada.
Correct, yeah.
And you get on the bike.
I get on the bike.
Right.
Thinking that I got this.
Was it duathlon at the time
or just I'm gonna be a cyclist?
I wanted to be a pro, I want to be a pro racer.
You wanted to be a pro cyclist?
Yeah, pro cyclist.
So how do you even begin to pursue that?
Well for one, it was a hard transition.
You know you think about the life that I'm just leaving
to become a normal citizen you know?
So it took a bit of time for that.
And you hadn't spent decades riding your bike around?
Coming up in the traditional sense.
No.
You're 30 at this point
and you're like, I'm gonna be a pro cyclist?
And people thought I was insane.
Like what the hell?
Like even like the president
of the National Acadian Cycling Team
or the Federation I should say, right?
He says, you're not zero, you've missed the boat,
you're too old, you can't sprint very well,
your mentality is...
I mean he didn't know me right you know.
And they basically shunned me off
so I had to prove to them that even though I was 30
which is basically the end of a lot of careers in cycling,
and here I am wanting to start it that I have this
and I can do this sport on a national, international level.
So how did you plead your case?
I had to go out there and show them who I was
and I'm telling you it was embarrassing because...
I mean, in the first part of pro racing
I excelled very fast to, you know it's got categories.
But when you hit the pro level of whatever racing,
I mean I would go into these races and I was relying
on my fitness but cycling is very much like a chess game.
You have to think three moves before you make your own move.
It's not a matter of who's the strongest,
it's who's the smartest.
And I go into these races and I come in so last
that I wouldn't even know where the finish was.
I'd see my car in an empty parking lot,
okay yeah, this must be it.
Yeah, so you go from being kind of a big fish
in a small pond to immediately realizing
that the pond is quite large.
Yeah, I'm a shrimp in an ocean now.
So how do you bridge that gap?
Well, at this point like I'm now 38 years old, right?
And I'm kinda making myself sound worse than what I was,
but I was racing for a pro team, a U.S. pro team.
I was at a big race in Redlands, California
and I heard a team director talking about a rider,
remember I'm 38 now, right?
But what happened between 30 and 38.
I'm struggling.
I'm wanting to-
But you're staying in it?
I'm staying in it because I-
So for eight years you're trying
to become this pro cyclist-
You bet.
Unsuccessfully.
Because I never quit anything in my life
and I'm determined to get there.
I mean also it contrast to like,
hey, listen, every sport I sign up for
I'm the world champion within months.
So this is a humbling-
Oh, totally.
Change of pace.
It was completely something I'd never experienced before
but a good lesson though.
But in honesty, like I was saying, I was in a race
and a team director was talking about a rider.
And he basically said, when the road goes up,
she drops down, which means he's referring to climbing.
And those five words that I'd never forget till the day
I die is Goldstein is my last name, can't climb more shit.
And everyone starts laughing,
not just him but other directors and coaches
and other riders and whatnot.
And it was at that moment that I said, you know what,
I'm gonna show you guys exactly what I can do.
And I basically in that one year, I hired a climbing coach.
I moved to like from Vancouver to Vernon
which is more hilly, bike friendly location,
I dropped about 10 pounds.
And I came back the following season at 38 years old,
not only winning hilly races but setting new records.
So it was that transition that fast.
At 38 competing against women who are
probably 10 years your junior.
Oh way, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
You need somebody to just follow you around and tell you,
you can't do stuff.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
You should pay somebody to do that.
I love when people say I can't do things.
(Leah laughs)
But wow, I didn't realize there was an eight year period
of just kind of utter humiliation and staying in it
and struggling but persisting.
It was a tough go, it was really, really tough.
And there's nothing really romantic
about pro cycling at that level.
Like it's a grind and there's no money.
But you were on a team like where you getting a stipend?
Were you able to support yourself
or did you have a job doing something else?
Well, I was smart when I was younger I saved my money
and I got into real estate very young.
When I came back, when I left Israel came back to Canada,
it was more affordable back then, right?
So I started to invest 'cause I was a saver.
And I was a trainer, I worked at gyms and stuff but-
So you're training like combat sports
but you're competing on the bike.
Right, exactly.
Yeah, wow.
That's interesting too just
from a physiological perspective because cycling
is all about just dropping as much weight in the upper body
as possible and being skinny as possible.
Exactly. But like I said though,
I mean, it's very much a team sport too, pro racing,
not like ultra endurance racing.
You know you have one rider and then you have your team
that they're your domestic.
And they're protecting you from the wind,
they're getting you food, they're chasing things down.
So, I had to learn all of that.
And it's a process, I think for pro racers,
I think many people will agree with me that it takes
about five years before you actually start getting good
and start learning what you're good at.
And riding with the national team too,
they sent me to Europe which is night and day compared
to North America, like the level of racing.
So when I came back from Europe to North America,
I mean, my level had jumped two folds.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome but I wanna snag
a moment to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire
to incorporate more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables,
seeds, beans, and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plantpower Meal Planner.
Our affordable all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com
and right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people for just $70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
So, backtracking a little bit though,
at 38, you come back after the off season
and you're a completely different rider.
You're approaching it much more strategically,
you've got this climbing coach
and you have these breakthroughs.
I presume that then garners the notice
of these team directors and how do you kind of progress
through the ranks at that point?
Oh my God, at that point...
I mean, I could have gone to any team, you know what I mean?
They're like, what do you want?
The difference was that drastic?
It was that drastic.
I mean, even doing it as a one woman team
and showing them what I could do, right?
But I don't know if you know that
when I reached the peak kind of at that point
where opportunities were handed to me,
I had the mother of all crashes in Cascade
and where I wanted to kind of to prove myself
on a more international field where there were teams
from the Ukraine and Russia and you know,
Kristin Armstrong in the United States was there.
And so let's see if I could really climb
against the best riders in the world and so I went to
that particular race and I knew on the first,
that first stage there was a long climb
that they would take off and they took off and I could...
I was the only rider in that peloton and whatever
that could hold that kind of
that really fast paced up the climb.
But then you know, you start descending.
On those bikes, you can go very fast almost up to,
what is it?
100 kilometers an hour, 80 miles an hour.
And as we're descending, other riders are starting
to come up and we're, and I'm seeing like 85, 86.
And then there's a rider kinda coming on my left-hand side.
And there's a center line rule and she kinda leans into me
at 80 kilometers an hour, I landed on my face.
So I basically lips off, instant face lift.
Right, your whole face peeled off.
Yeah, I mean I broke almost 20 bones in my body.
The friction of the fall burned off the first layer of skin.
It was a nightmare.
I mean, I shouldn't be sitting here today based
on that crash, right?
So that was 2005, right?
Prior to that you had gone on this like tear winning
a bunch of races, right?
Like between, you won like nine out of 11 races leading up
to that Cascade Classic?
So you were in a pretty great position
in terms of really making a stamp on the pro circuit.
Oh, absolutely.
Although you'd had another,
you were in a position to make the 2004 Olympic team
but you had another crash, right?
That kinda took you out of contention for that.
Yeah.
And then you come back from that,
you don't make the Olympic team because of that crash.
But the Cascade Classic
is really gonna be this moment to shine.
Well, the Cascade Classic was kind of...
I mean, it was gonna be after that race
that I was gonna make my decision of, okay where am I gonna
like my breakthrough kinda riding career.
But being in that position,
I mean they basically told me that your career is over.
Your ability to walk properly without a walker
or cane will be very limited.
And then 100% you won't be back on your bike again.
And that's what I was left with as I was lying there
and you know in the trauma unit.
So, I believe, correct me if I'm wrong,
like Vail News dubbed this crash
like the most epic crash of all time, correct?
At that time, correct, yes.
Is it on film?
The crash?
Yeah.
No, I don't think so, I don't think they filmed the...
I mean, they did articles on it, right?
I mean we have pictures of the after a surgery stuff
but there is big write-ups on it
but I don't think it was filmed, no.
So you went down at like somewhere
between 60 and 80 miles an hour.
Correct, yeah.
On a descent.
With everybody else falling on top of me.
On your teeth, your lips.
I mean, you can't tell looking,
did you have to have like a lot of plastic surgery?
Oh yeah, I had lots of surgery done around.
I mean, I'm still kinda numb on my right side here.
There is a difference if you look at my younger pictures,
my face to what it is now there is...
I mean it's, there was a little bit of a difference.
Skin shorn off, your torso.
Yeah.
And you were told that you might not walk properly again.
Correct, I mean I broke my...
Both my ischium was shattered, my hips were broken, my arms.
I mean, fingers and toes busted, I was...
It's like taking a pretzel and basically stepping on it.
I can't even explain to you the worst pain
I'd ever been through.
Everything hurt all the time, breathing, blinking,
people opening and closing the door the wind from that.
It was a tough go.
Wow, how long were you in the hospital?
Well, they couldn't move me out of the United States
for I think four weeks.
And then they transferred me to...
'Cause I had to be airlifted from the crash
to St. Charles in Bend, Oregon.
And then my sister came to pick me up 'cause I couldn't...
It was gonna take a bit of process to drive me back
to Canada 'cause also getting expensive
'cause medical is expensive here, right?
So, months in the hospital.
Yes.
But you have the gift of these doctors telling you,
you're not gonna walk again let alone get on a bike
and ever race again, right?
So what do you do with that information?
You know what I said to them in my head,
I won't say it on air, gonna show you.
I mean, how do you begin the rehab process?
Well listen, the only thing
I could do was contract my abs.
That was the only physical thing I could do.
But I basically made a promise to myself and I said,
I don't care how long it takes
or the kind of pain I'm gonna go through,
I'm gonna get back on that bike, I'm gonna race again
and I'm gonna come back even stronger
than I did before all this happened.
And I think, it happened to a lot of people when your faced
with this overwhelming situations,
you don't know what to do so you kinda buckle.
So I knew I had a lot of work cut out for me
but I think everything is upstairs.
It's what you believe in, what you make your body believe
that you can do.
Because honestly, if I believed everything
that I was told even growing up,
then I wouldn't again, I wouldn't be sitting here today.
Right.
But we all have our breaking points too.
We do.
But your ability to kind of come compartmentalize all
of that and just focus on, okay I can do this.
Like how much of your military training comes into play
in terms of having the mental rigor to just block
out the fear and focus on the task at hand.
I think the military has a lot to do with it
because it was part of their job
even during my military train to crack us mentally
as best as they can, right?
'Cause mental strength is much more powerful
than physical strength, we all know that.
But for me, like at that point going back to the hospital,
I mean, how can they say something like that?
I haven't even started my rehab, you know what I mean?
Just to make that kind of prediction that fast.
And I think that's the thing is that we're so quick
to take the easy way out without being more optimistic
of the things that we possibly can do.
And the possibilities of just going after the things
that you believe in.
'Cause sometimes you're not gonna get support
from other people, you're gonna have to believe in yourself.
That's the thing is we're so influenced by other sources.
But for me, I never was, never has been, never will be.
What I wanna do and what I'm determined to do,
I'll make it happen.
I'll find a way to make it happen.
So make it happen you did.
Like how long was the rehabilitation
before you could get back on a bike?
I was back on my bike, race ready in less than a season.
So like-
Eight months.
Eight months, wow, wow.
And I was really skinny because I had my...
My lips had to be sown back on so I couldn't eat anything.
So I was climbing like a fin.
(Leah laughs)
So how long before you could walk properly
like take me through the stages of-
Well I mean, okay well, it was tough.
I mean I had a lot of rehab on my own,
I was in a wheelchair.
So I remember asking my mom to drop me off
at like a running track.
And I had one arm that I...
And my ankle, my left ankle, I can't move very well but...
And so I'd just wheel around the track as much as I can
and then I'd start using more, but mobility...
In a wheelchair.
Yeah, in a wheelchair.
But mobility was really important,
is getting those muscles strong again.
And it hurt like a son of a gun.
But every day I was better than the day before
and just staying positive and honesty,
it's sort of got being in that positive mode,
I could feel things starting to bind.
'Cause when I went to get re X-rayed at the general hospital
in Vancouver, a couple of months later,
they were floored at how fast I was recovering.
And you attribute that to just being in motion and-
I think in motion and mentally, you know what I mean.
And just determined that I am gonna get out of this.
Yeah.
So from the wheelchair then, like how do...
I mean, are you walking with a limp like how was-
Oh, yeah no, it goes from wheelchair to a one crutch.
You know what I mean?
Bopping away and then...
I mean, it was even a wheelchair to wheeling to my trainer
which was on a bike, whatever.
And it took me like 40 minutes just to get
from the wheelchair, just to sit and be comfortable
on the bike because it was the flashbacks.
Yeah, when you say you were race ready or back on the bike
and ready to race eight months later,
that doesn't account for the kind of mental trauma
of the recurring, like imagery of like crashing
at that kind of speed, right?
Absolutely, yeah.
And pro cycling, you have to be absolutely fearless.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Like how do you ever descend aggressively again
after that experience?
Far away from the peloton.
How could you ever overcome that?
Yeah, like there's no way 'cause the edge that you have
to ride in order to be competitive at the elite level
is to really embrace that fearlessness.
And that's funny because that's why a lot of the races
I did, I tried to get into breakaways
where I wasn't with like early before.
Just right off the front at the beginning.
Or on the climbs, just take off so I don't have
to descend with anyone.
That might work like one out
of every 20 races but most of the time,
then you end up getting completely destroyed.
Yeah, I mean for sure.
I mean that was the hardest thing.
I mean with ascending, climbing was easy for me, right?
It was the descending that was really...
I mean I'd be breaking all the time and my climbing coach
that I hired earlier to make me this great climber,
he was now coaching me to descend without being...
Without having this fear because you know
you can't race having that kind of fear.
Right.
And there is a risk.
And with that fear, you become a hazard
to the other riders.
Absolutely yeah.
But mind you too, I mean, I was kinda like...
When we were descending, I would kind of veer off
to the side a little bit more, give myself more space.
Try to stay to the front as much as possible.
And I realized too like after that crash,
I mean I had great years the next three years after
but I couldn't afford to crash 'cause you know,
I think two years after that I was hit
by the car in Redlands.
Oh, I don't know about that.
Yeah, it's actually one of my,
close to my last year of racing in a criterion was
at Redland stage race and we were warming up for the crit
and I was coming back to the team car
and this lady in a Hyundai who was texting,
she was going like 80 kilometers an hour, 50 miles an hour
or whatever, she hits me from the rear of the bike
and ejected me off my bike and I landed like Superman
onto the pavement and stabbed both my hands,
I had two compound fractures.
You know like, gosh, here we go again. (Leah laughs)
So what are you like at this point 40 something?
I'm now 42, yeah.
And so I had retired that, I said, I can't do this anymore.
Were you the oldest rider on the peloton?
No, no Jeannie Longo, he's the most decorated athlete,
she was older.
Linda Jackson was in there too.
So there was more.
I mean, I think women pushed the envelope a little bit more
than the men with racing.
So, but I was...
I mean, I had planned to kinda transition
into ultra-endurance racing during that time
but that was just, yeah, the accident was-
Because no crazy descents.
I know I have the mental fortitude for something like this,
I don't crack easily.
Like this could be something to pursue.
While you're racing you're starting to think about that?
Well, I mean I think the reality is that I had crushed.
That's not the only crash you have,
when you're a pro racer, you crashed multiple times.
I broke my back in France when I was there
and multiple crashes where I cracked my helmet, right?
I mean, I think to the safety of me
like there's life after cycling.
It just felt like a right time to transition
'cause I really wanted to do ultra endurance racing,
which is a lot safer in that regards.
And so, just I didn't make it there without that last.
So after that crash or where the car hit you at Redlands,
that was like the final moment, like I'm done.
Correct, yes.
Done being a pro racer.
Yeah.
So what happens?
You go back to Canada and start
to hatch some plan to become?
Well, the plan was Race Across America.
I mean I remember watching that and saying,
I'm gonna do that before I retire completely from cycling.
'Cause the goal was, I mean, I just felt like I would...
I was be born gifted,
I was more gifted for ultra endurance racing based
on my ability to ignore pain, push myself beyond my limits
and to be functionable with very little sleep.
That's military training.
Yeah, yeah, walk me through the military training
around sleep deprivation 'cause this is
like a superpower that you have.
And I'm sort of the mind
that you can develop mental fortitude around it
but it's also not something you can you truly train it?
Like in my experience 'cause I've tried to practice it,
and then when you get to the event
and you need to rely on it, it doesn't really work.
Yeah.
Like practicing it doesn't make it any easier.
No, I think from what I understand
that either you have it or you don't.
That you can't, there's something you can't train.
I don't know, that's based on some research.
There're some people who are just constitutionally wired
to be like, when you hear these legendary stories
of some of the RAAM racers over the years,
like your aerobic and all these people
who could literally just sleep an hour a night
and seem to churn it out no problemo.
It's not no problemo but it comes with challenges, right?
Like you hallucinate really bad and stuff.
But yeah your body, you just become like a potato,
you don't know what's real what's not real
like a lot of time with sleep deprivation during
a Race Across America, I didn't know
what I was doing on the bike.
Because I too, we too have my sleep to 90 minutes.
But you had experience with that.
Like in military training, they're probably waking you up
in the middle of the night all the time.
Oh, they're not even waking up, you're awake.
(both laughs)
There is no I'm waking you up.
I mean-
But mind games, there's a lot of mind games.
Oh totally, oh yeah.
I mean, I remember once training, we had a really hard trek,
it was through the night.
We finished the trek after I think nine or 10 hours,
we come back to our base or barracks or whatever.
The commander says, you guys can rest,
we'll give you four hours and then we're back at it, right?
So we're all, thank God and I'm thinking you know what,
this is too good to be true.
If he says that, you know that's not gonna be there.
And so she leaves and then 30 seconds later,
another guy comes in, opens the lights,
he says get your stuff back on,
we're heading back out again.
Right.
So that's the kind of stuff that they,
you know what I mean?
And people are crying and screaming and-
That's very instructive for ultra endurance.
Yeah, exactly.
So, that was called.
I mean, if something sounds too good to be true,
you know it's not gonna happen.
Right.
Yeah.
So you're going into this idea around RAAM
with a very specific set of skills.
I mean, there are other...
Like some of these Eastern European guys
who've raced RAAM I think are military officers, right?
Correct.
Some of the great guys over the years.
So it's not a new thing that somebody with your discipline
and background would be interested in this
but you are coming into it
with this pro cycling career plus the military training.
I mean, you're positioned well for it.
I'm positioning well, mentally for it absolutely, right?
You know, I mean I think that has a lot...
The benefits of that.
But even in pro racing,
I mean I was better in longer races, I got stronger later.
Again, I could stay awake.
And so I just thought things that were extended and longer,
my ability to recover really fast too
was another asset that I had.
So, I just felt like it was more suited for me again,
ultra endurance racing.
Yeah, so the first time you do...
You've done RAAM three times, right?
So what was...
The first year was 2011?
Correct.
Yeah.
So talk to me about how you transitioned your training
to prepare for that.
Well, I mean-
It's a very different thing.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I didn't hire a coach or whatever.
So I just knew I had to stay on my bike and ride it nonstop.
And so what I did is I just self-trained
and even my crew, none of us did it before.
We didn't know what we were getting into, right?
So I would train multiple...
Like at 3:00 in the morning or 6:00 in the morning
or 12:00 at night so you know,
just to train my body and I thought I knew I was doing it
and I basically come to the line.
At that point, I thought in the best shape
of my life, right?
But Race Across America is a different animal.
It's something you can't...
It's really hard to describe it in words.
'Cause remember you have 12 days to get your body
across the country.
So, a lot of things happen during that time.
It's not a matter of if but when.
You know you have back neck, knee, constipation,
diarrhea, swelling, and you have to have a crew
that knows what they're doing navigational wise,
keeping you safe, knowing the terrain,
knowing when there's a bike change.
So, we kinda went in there completely green.
Yeah.
We should probably explain for people that are listening
or watching who don't know what RAAM is.
RAAM is a cycling race that began like 40 years ago.
Yeah, 39 years ago, correct.
That entails riding your bike across the country
on a predesignated route.
You begin in Oceanside, California, you end up in Annapolis.
Is it the same route every year?
Do they ever switch it up at all?
Now, it has the last...
They do switch up.
Like the first RAAM was, I started up Northmore,
it went through a different terrain
but a little bit shorter, less climbing.
But the last I'm gonna say 10 years,
it's been the Annapolis.
The same route, right?
Yeah.
There's a solo division where people like yourselves,
just do it the way they wanna do it
and then there are relay divisions which is different.
And that's super interesting too and the way
that the relays decide how to configure their rotation,
whether they're gonna do six hour shifts
or 30 minute shifts, it's super fascinating.
But in any of that, the idea is you ride your bike
across the country and you can sleep as much as you want
or you can sleep not at all, it's completely up to you.
You're supported by a crew that follows you,
that supports you, that feeds you
and that's gotta be an unbelievably rigorous job.
And there are legendary stories of people
who have attempted this, who have succeeded at doing this.
And it's...
There are tales of woe and tears
and hallucinations and cry.
I mean like the drama is unbelievable.
Oh yeah.
Even with, and don't forget too,
you've got 12 days to do it.
So when you say you can sleep as much
as you want not necessarily, right.
Because if you sleep-
12 days ain't that much.
Yeah, I mean in a 48 hour period,
it's either zero to three hours but most people,
every like, you always go through the first start
so you're gonna ride about the first 40 hours nonstop.
And then you'll go into your sleep cycle of every 24 hours
from like 90 minutes to three hours
I'm gonna say it's usually the time.
And your sleep schedule evolved through the experience
of these three races before you kinda figured out
what works best for you.
Yeah, I mean you learn something on.
I mean, that was a total learning curve
the first time, right.
You know also I got the condition of shermers neck.
Yeah, we're gonna spend a lot of time talking about that.
That was even more of a challenge.
So, that's the thing like the neck gives out
'cause you can't hold your eight to 10 pound head up
in that position for that amount
of time without it giving out and people's necks
just can't sustain their heads
and their heads end up resting on their hands basically
on the handlebars and it becomes a very perilous.
I mean, yeah.
I mean I didn't even know what Shermer's neck was.
I mean, when we started Race Across America in 2011...
I mean, I basically started the race like a jackass,
I went out through like a bat out of hell,
riding like I was a pro racer, right.
And I was good for three days.
Just blasted off through the desert in California.
And on day like two and a half, I thought okay,
I was on record breaking pace, I can sustain this is hard
but everything's good.
But then eventually, and shermers that happens,
it's like a slow onset, it's fast, right.
Then all of a sudden,
I was having a hard time keeping my head up,
'cause our neck isn't positioned, built to hold our head up,
it's there to support it, not to hold it.
So, I couldn't turn my head anymore
and then all of a sudden within three hours
of the first pain that kinda shut down my back
into my buttocks area.
My head completely dropped so my chin
is now resting on my chest.
You can't lift your head.
I cannot, I cannot lift it.
How many days in were you?
Two and a half days.
And so in order to ride the bike now, like you said,
I'm holding my head in my chin under the palm of my hand,
the other arm is steering braking and trying
to control the bike.
And so my crew members are saying, oh my God,
we're not even a quarter of the way into the race,
we have to pull out, you can't ride across the country.
And I remember saying you know what,
I've never quit anything in my life,
I don't care if I have to crawl across,
come up with something, we're gonna make it across.
So my crew is creative, they're really creative.
They came up with different apparatuses,
one was like a PVC pipe thing whatever
with a sling underneath.
I've seen lots of videos of that.
You have this PVC pipe going down your back
and then you literally like tape it to your forehead.
You look like you just got out of the spinal ward
at the hospital, it's insane.
Yeah. But none of those...
Another one was a big like an arm coming off your handlebars
like that you rest your chin on.
That seemed dangerous.
What worked for me that I still use in all my rounds
is gonna sound kinda crazy.
So, in every round, basically shaved my ear from ear to ear.
My hair is a little bit short here.
And then with the remainder of hair that's on the top
of my head, my crew chief will take tensor bandage,
she'll french braid it into three sections
on the top of my head.
She'll pull my head back and she'll tie it to the back
of my heart rate monitor.
It's kinda like a bubble we have whatever.
In the later races,
you actually wove cloth into those braids
so you could pull it down.
Correct, yeah.
And then you anchor it to your heart rate monitor,
strap on the back.
Yup, yup.
But that strap is,
I mean that strap would have to be pretty tight, right?
It's pretty tight.
But I start with that now too, I don't wait
until it gets really bad because I think they said
that shermer is actually really prone to people
who have suffered from whiplash or injury crashes.
So, and it's usually male not a lot of women.
So I think from the crash that I've had in the past.
And yeah, that's how I got across the country.
I mean, lemme tell you, it was the worst pain
I'd ever suffered through because your muscles
are so tight and it's so tense.
I mean, we had to rotate Aleve, Tylenol and Advil
just to control the pain, I'd be throwing up off the side
of the bike because of the pain.
It was excruciating.
But then with the weird contraption that you have,
does it feel like your hair is getting pulled out
of your head the whole time.
Absolutely,
it feels like it, they'll tell you to go run,
I'll grab you by the hair but you keep running, right.
That's what it feels like but I mean,
what else are you gonna do?
Nothing else worked, right.
And otherwise I can't see the road.
So that's either I get my hair pulled or I crash.
So 2011, you figure it out and you finish it.
But that was really just an education
in what this experience was all about.
I mean, I'm still able to, I still won the race.
I mean, I didn't set any records or anything.
And then I-
You won the women's female division.
Correct, yes.
Solo.
And then at that point I was done living out of my bags,
as you know I was pro racing for so many years,
then RAAM was kind of, and I was just ready to take a break.
So I actually-
How dare you?
Yeah, I know, I know.
You hadn't taken a break your whole life.
(Leah laughs)
You like 40, were you 42, 43 at this point?
Well, 2011 yeah, you probably 41.
42, yeah.
42 and so then I just wanted to...
I just needed a mental break whatever
and so then I ended up writing the book
and started speaking but I didn't like not do anything,
I started doing duathlons and marathons.
'Cause I'm always gonna keep active and if it's important.
You're making a living in real estate,
like how do you pay the bills?
I bought, well, that's what I'm saying,
that I bought properties young when I was young
and I was able to own lots of properties.
That's nice, it's good for the training lifestyle.
Oh, for sure.
To have that freedom to do whatever
you want was important to me.
But I started doing...
I was with the Acadian speaking bureau
so I started doing presentations.
And just doing other things but then I...
The itch to come back to RAAM and to write it better
because I think the first time you do it,
it's a learning experience.
And I was just determined to go after the 10 day record.
It was just something that,
but I think I just took a little bit too much time off.
I took almost seven years off the bike
and then I went back into the ultra endurance racing.
Right, so the next RAAM was 2019, 18?
Correct, yeah.
It was on my 50th birthday,
I said, I'm gonna gift myself a present.
50th birthday and you had this experience under your belt.
Like so how does that change
how you prepare for the second attempt?
It was hard because a lot of time had gone by.
You know what I mean?
And I think to be out of the loop for that long.
But I wanted to do...
And there's a big difference between 50 and 42 and 41.
Yeah, totally agree, right.
So what I wanna do is prove to myself
that I could still ride my bike.
So I went into Silver State 508, the one in Nevada.
And I kinda crammed in training and I ended up setting
a new woman's record and I said,
okay, I can still ride my bike.
But I think the prep going into the 2019 RAAM,
a little bit over-trained, overdid it, I was too excited
and yeah, so I think we came in there...
I came in there a little bit cupped.
But you broke the women's record by like 12 hours.
No, no, no.
Oh, you didn't?
Not in that race.
I read that wrong then.
No, that was RAW, that was RAW, the first RAW in 2012.
But in the 2019 race though,
it was the hardest women's field the race had ever had.
There was I think six RAAM champions in there.
So it was a race.
Like right from the beginning right to the end.
And so Isah and Alexandra
who's already the younger group category
from Sweden and Austria were the favorites to win
but it ended up to be Daniella and I,
with them like 24 hours back.
But a lot of things happen and so again,
I think we had issues navigational stuff
and I ended up losing by 90 minutes
and that's why I had decided that I'm coming back again.
90 minutes.
After all of that.
And what you are 11 plus days or something like that?
No, 10 Days.
10 days.
10 days yeah, 19 hours.
And the record is like seven plus-
No, that's for the men.
I know for the men, like the fastest time ever recorded.
The fastest time on that course, not on the course
that was shorter, on that course is 10 is days.
Oh it is.
Yeah it is 10 days.
For men and women.
No for women.
But for men, like who's the fastest has ever gone?
I believe Strasser of seven days.
Yeah, he has for that, yeah.
So there's two different courses,
there is a shorter course of Shannon Hogan holds
that record, but they go based on average speed.
But we're talking about just the course,
but for that course, it's Nicole Reese from Sweden,
sorry, from Austria, she has the course record of 10 days.
To make it across on that course in 11 days,
just for people that are listening,
like you have to be averaging at least
like 12 miles an hour including sleep
for the whole thing, right?
Pretty close, yeah.
Yeah.
So that provides a little context.
Right, right, oh yeah.
Wow.
So 2019, you re-establish yourself
but also like a sense of unfinished business?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was determined-
This cannot stand.
Well, I mean like you said...
I just had to come back, right?
I mean, I wrote down everything that,
the mistakes that we made, the mistakes that I made.
What mistakes did you make?
Well for me I was overconfident.
I mean, I think I focused way too much on climbing.
I mean RAAM has got a lot of climbing
but there's a lot of flats going through Kansas
and Illinois and whatnot.
To work more on power,
we had to get a better navigational system
'cause I think we probably had about two and a half
to almost three hours of navigational error,
which hurt us quite badly.
Like going off course, you mean?.
Correct, yeah.
And when you go off course,
you have to jump back into cargo back to a place
where you made a mistake and then start from there, right?
So on day six we messed up four times.
And so, I mean-
And you have the same crew though.
You have the same crew.
I mean the same crew that you had in 2011.
A little bit changes here and there, like a few people.
But when there was so many detours too because of the floods
in the Mississippi, you know what I mean?
And that we got notification a little bit later,
but you know what?
That's the nature of the race, it's RAAM,
it's 3000 miles, you're gonna mess up.
There's always gonna be some crazy stuff.
You just wanna catch it really fast, right?
So we worked on the navigational issue part for this,
like for the Ram 2021 or 2022 sorry.
Yeah and then again, I came in way better but don't forget,
we had the COVID year where RAAM...
We were all set to go and then we got notification in April
that the race was canceled.
But I continued to train like I was racing
'cause I knew the benefits would lead me into to this year.
To use that as a benefit.
Sorry.
The idea that the race got canceled rather
than looking at that as a setback,
like, oh I have a whole nother year to train.
Absolutely, yeah.
So I even came back even I could even do more
to up my training even more in the next following year.
Yeah.
Sustaining power on the flats is,
like seems to be a key to success
because there are so many flats.
I think in cycling, you know climbing,
it's a lot of attention, people can climb well.
But it's actually really hard to sustain
like threshold power on flats for a long period of time.
Like the level of pain that goes into that-
Oh my God, absolutely.
Exceeds often like what it's required to attack a climb.
Yeah, absolutely.
Oh for sure.
I mean, but even with climbing...
Like my crew chief always says,
the only time you're gonna feel good in RAAM
is the first few days.
After that, you're running off fumes it's mental.
So you're not climbing like you're gonna climb on a timer
or whatever but to hold that sustained power,
like you said on the flats especially when you're in Kansas
and you have a headwind for 19 hours,
that's more difficult than climbing Wolf Creek Pass
or whatever in Colorado that's 10,000 feet.
So, you really have to balance what you're gonna do
and you can't neglect any element
where I was only focusing on climbing in the 2011 or 2019.
But this time I really balanced it out between the two
so it was much more powerful but also bike positioning.
You know, being aero is one thing, it's great.
But if you're uncomfortable after like staying-
No, comfort is way more important.
Oh absolutely.
So I worked on a better...
Rob Bright, he set me up how a RAAM rider should feel.
Which is more upright.
More upright.
Less pressure on your wrists.
Absolutely.
And your shoulders.
Yeah, that has to be key getting that right
and also finding the right saddle
'cause you're gonna get saddle sores no matter what.
Oh, you bet, there's no way around it.
How many saddles did you test before you found one
that was suitable?
I just used my one particular saddle
that just works for me.
It doesn't matter what saddle, it's just comfortable.
But you know, a saddle sore is a pressure point
and you're sitting on that pressure point
for so long that you're gonna get it no matter what,
but I think trying to prevent it from progressing too much
so sitting in Epsom salts really fast,
changing shorts as much as possible.
And then in worst case scenario,
you know you have the Lidocaine, right?
You just numb it all up.
Numb it up, yeah.
Oh God, it's the worst.
It is but you have to do, you have to do.
Yeah.
And it's that thing where it's the tiny things
that fell the journey, right?
It's the little tiny...
Oh, I have this little boil but then it's like,
it becomes your whole universe.
It's on your mind.
It capsizes the whole thing.
Totally, the tiniest little thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
What is the, sleep deprivation aspect aside
like how do you prepare mentally and like
what are the mantras that you repeat or what is going on
in your mind when you're living in that pain
for such an extended period of time
like are you telling yourself stories?
Are you just focused on your heart rate?
Like what is going on in your head?
I'm focused on a number of things.
Speed is a big thing but again it all depends on wind
and terrain.
If you're descending, if you're climbing.
I think too, somebody asked me that question before too
is like when you are that uncomfortable.
But I think, my mantras,
you have to learn to be comfortable being uncomfortable,
that's RAAM, right you know.
And a lot of times when we are in pain,
we focus on that pain, that's all we're thinking about.
So I try to kinda park it and not focus on that pain.
I know it sounds kinda strange but it works for me.
And thinking about the task in hand like what am I...
What have I done to get here?
The training that I've gone through
and you wanna get to that finish line, right?
So stop dwelling on the things that hurt you
and let's focused on what you need to do
to get to your finish line.
And I think that really worked for me.
And just yeah, I think preparing in the right way,
knowing what I was doing prior to is a big part
of completing RAAM in 10 to 12 days.
Yeah.
You said you've never quit anything
but I suspect there have been moments of weakness
where you were on the precipice of quitting
like how do you talk yourself off the ledge
in those situations?
Easy.
Or you just, you don't even get there.
No, of course, I mean...
The only thing I have to think about is how I'll regret it
and I'll just dwell on it for the rest of my life.
But it's like you've held that line,
like I've never quit anything so I'm not gonna start now.
Patterns are repeated.
There's no fissures in that wall.
Yeah, to me quitting should never be an option
unless it's life-threatening of course,
that's my mantra I've.
But what if you're...
I mean, there are situations in your life I'm sure
where you were pursuing something and you realize like,
well, this is not for me or this is not right.
Like it's not really quitting,
it's sort of changing directions.
I think people sometimes stay in things too long,
they probably should quit stuff sooner
and try something else.
Yeah, that's different.
So how do you differentiate?
I mean, I think whatever you choose to do,
you have to love it.
I think people like you were saying who go to a job,
they wake up in the morning
and they hate what they're doing, right?
I mean I find that sad and I think life is too short.
I mean, that happened to me in Israel.
My dream was to be a Belush agent
and work for intelligence till I was gonna retire,
45, you have a great pension in Israel, that was my dream.
I think having a purpose to what I was doing and loving
what I was doing was more important for me
than the ego of that job.
And I think whatever you choose,
do choose to do that you love it,
that when you wake up in the morning,
you have a motivation and a desire 'cause life's too short.
I mean, this is a one-time deal, this is our life,
let's make the best of it.
And so that kind of is my mantra forever.
That's how I live my life.
But when you're on hour 45 without sleep
and you forget where you are and you're not sure
what you're doing or what your feet are doing,
like how do you maintain that focus?
Like are there tactics or strategies that you deploy
to bring yourself back into your body
and remind yourself why you're doing it?
Like, what does that look like?
Like when we're talking about RAAM,
sometimes at that point, it's up to the crew
to say, you know what, you need 30 minutes off the bike.
When you're not moving and you're delirious
and it can be dangerous where like I mean,
at one point I was hallucinating so bad
that a Panther had jumped in front of me
that I veered over to the other side of the road.
So in that case, my crew is gonna stop me,
that's why it's very important,
there behind me all the time and I'm radioed to them.
And they'll say, you need 30 minutes.
So your crew is your lifeline, they're your brain
'cause you become like a puppet.
So that's why you have good communication before the race
of what's gonna transpire
if you can no longer make those rational decisions.
But, we all know what I'm there for.
And of course if it was life-threatening or dangerous,
my crew would pull me but it would...
That's the only way that they would ever pull me.
(indistinct)
If it wasn't safe.
Right.
On the Shermer's neck thing,
you trained for the most recent RAAM
by wearing a weighted helmet, right?
Correct, yes.
To try to strengthen those neck muscles.
I did intense strength exercises with my...
Not only that, it's like those...
It's like a harness you wear over your head
and it's got weighted plates.
I do a lot of like reps out like that (indistinct).
And always, always when I'm on the trainer,
I always have a one pound helmet on.
You'll see I have three little plates on top of my helmet.
And when I ride, I have one little plate,
so I have different weights.
And so I always have some kind of load on my head.
So when I wear the helmet, it feels like nothing.
And that does help.
It's not a complete cure, but it does make your neck
a little bit stronger for sure.
Still gotta shave the head and-
Still gotta shave the head, yeah.
All right, so going into the 2021 RAAM,
what was the goal?
The goal was 10 days,
you know that was kinda the big goal.
I think that in to get the women's 50 record right.
And make it across within the 12 days
of course and be safe.
It's really hard to plan 'cause you don't know
what you're gonna face.
We went 10 days earlier for the heat to kinda climatize
to those temperatures to break us.
You knew it was gonna be a hot year.
Well, I mean there was a heat wave that was...
We didn't know like it was gonna be that hot,
I don't think anybody knew, right?
A week before, it was like 90 degrees in Borrego Springs
which was quite pleasant.
I have that at home, do you know what I mean?
But then all of a sudden, we checked the forecast
and the day of the race, like when RAAM started,
it was about 85 and then as soon as we hit the desert,
like four hours later, it went from 85 to 110.
I mean, descending down the glass elevator,
I could feel my eyeballs burning.
And I don't think anybody was prepared
for what we were getting into this year.
Yeah.
And if it's 110, then the pavement's probably 120.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
And just the reflection off the pavement,
the heat is super oppressive.
It was the most intense feeling I'd ever...
I mean, even in Israel where it's very difficult and hot,
we'd never experienced anything like that before.
And the trick, the thing was the heat didn't abate,
like it wasn't just through the desert,
like it was an unprecedented heat wave
for the entire experiment.
Even at nighttime, I mean it...
I mean the only pleasantry at night
is that you didn't have the blazing sun on you
but it was still excruciating hot,
like it was just...
I mean in Kansas I burned right through my jersey,
it was that intense, the heat was that intense.
So with that, the challenge is
how do I keep my core temperature from overheating?
So what strategies did you deploy with ice and the like
to try to ameliorate your body just boiling over?
Well, for one, the jersey.
Like jerseys aren't very friendly for hot temperature
so we just use a cotton men's t-shirt.
You know we had cut slice just to keep it cool.
I had like a veil, so it wouldn't burn my neck.
And then in the real intense heat,
it's like an ice sock, like a long sock like a scarf full
of ice wrapped around my neck.
And then every, I'm gonna say three to four miles,
one of my crew members would stand on the side of a road
with a bottle of water that I could dump over,
douche was over my head.
And I would dry within, I'm gonna say six minutes,
I would be completely dry.
And then even that wasn't enough
so we had to stop a couple of time for IVs,
I needed about three bags of IVs
'cause it was getting dangerously dehydrated.
That's permitted under the rules?
That's permitted, yeah.
And the RAAM rules are pretty strict
in terms of what you can and can't do.
Correct, but when it's life threatening like that,
I mean, I think all of us did.
I mean the two guys that were behind me, they didn't have...
I had a doctrine nurse with me so they could give me the IV,
but they also got the IV in the hospital
and everyone else had dropped out, right?
Even teams had dropped out early into the race
especially during through California and Arizona.
So how many towed the line
and then how many ended up finishing?
I finished on Saturday, 11 days.
I believe it was three hours and then 17 hours after me,
Eric was the first male and then two hours after him,
the last rider came in.
Only three people finished.
Yeah, and I believe that the teams...
What about relays?
I'm not exactly sure don't quote me on this
but I believe half of them did drop out.
That's when you know it's bad.
You know it's bad.
Because if the relays are dropping out
where they're getting rest, it's gotta be insane.
Yeah I mean, just try standing
in those temperatures let alone ride, right?
Yeah it was crazy.
And on top of that like in Kansas...
'Cause at that point it was between myself and Mark
who was leading the field at that time,
he was from the United Kingdom.
We both had a headwind for like I'm gonna say close
to 20 hours, it was just relentless.
Wow, at what point...
So you complete the race in 11 days, three hours.
You are the first woman to ever win the race outright
in the 39 year history of this race.
At what point during the race did you feel like you had
a shot at winning?
Well, it was kind of a way in the back of my head
in the start, right?
I mean I knew Mark was a nine dayer, right?
I mean, he's done it I think, I believe nine times,
the man from the United Kingdom.
He was the favorite to win,.
I mean, when I kind of knew it was
when I passed him in the Appalachians.
But I didn't do no victory speech or anything like that
because anything can happen during RAAM,
you know what I mean?
You don't do that because I still had a lot of miles to go.
The Appalachians is what really separates everybody.
Yeah, I mean that's the hardest.
Yeah, the climbs are steeper
like the rock was kinda more gradual,
these are steep, sharp climbs
and it's just climb after climb after climb.
And I was kind of, when him and I were going back and forth,
I was kinda trying to conserve as much as possible
because that's kind of where my strength is the climbing.
But I think he pulled out before we even...
As we were getting into the Appalachians,
I think he pulled out of the race.
But as you said, anything can happen
and you almost didn't finish within almost seeing distance
of the finished line.
Oh my God, yeah.
(both laughs)
Yeah, oh my gosh, yeah.
I'll never forget that till the day I die.
So, I mean, I think that day I was really overheated,
electrolyte balance is super important
to keep everything intact and I was hot and tired
and I wasn't eating, I wasn't drink really
as much as I wanted to and just wanting
to get the thing over with and all of a sudden,
my heart just elevated like it was beating
at 200 beats an hour and I got super busy.
10 beats a minute, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, 10 minutes, sorry.
And I basically fell off my bike onto a patchy grass.
It was on the right side, thank God it was there you know?
And I just started to tremble
and I've never experienced that before.
And so my crew comes out, they're trying to cool me down
and I said, you know what?
And the finish is right there
and I'm terrified 'cause I can't get up, right?
And so I relaxed a little bit more than I get up
and I said you know what, I'm allowed to walk with the bike.
You can't have any help, so no one touched me so my crew-
And you got like 10 hours on the guy behind you.
Yeah, no, I had-
The least right? More than that?
At that point I had 17 hours, right.
But still you wanna come to the finish.
I mean people are waiting for.
You know it was crazy.
So I start walking the bike with...
So my crew member, she gives me her pink running shoes
so you can see me walking, there's pictures of me walking
with the bike and then into the actual finish,
it's a little bit of a descend.
So I didn't wanna walk, I was kind of embarrassed
so I said, you know what, I can get and just roll into.
So you can see in the real finish of Race Across America,
I'm rolling in and then you can see two crew members running
beside me to catch me just in case I fall off my bike.
If you tipped over and you've got running shoes on.
I have running shoes on, these big oversized,
pink running shoes and then as soon as I crossed the line,
you see the ambulance, the fire department come
and they're all taking my vitals and wanting me
to go to the hospital and all that kind of stuff, right?
So, it was-
Wow.
But that was honestly, it was a scary moment<
I was in total panic mode.
Do you have memory of that?
I mean sometimes when that kinda stuff happens
like you're in a semi blackout.
No, I remember very well.
You do, you do?
I remember the panic on my face,
the panic on my crew's face go,
oh my God, it's like right there.
I mean, you can smell it, right?
That close, but I mean...
Like I said, I mean I had a pretty good cushion,
a good lead on the guy behind but you still wanna,
there's a crowd waiting for you and you know-
Yeah, you wanna look good crossing that line
and that's you're gonna...
The picture is gonna get taken right.
Yeah, exactly.
So 52 years old, first woman to ever win this race.
I mean, what does that say about athletic potential
as we age and also the difference between men and women
when it comes to endurance and ultra endurance specifically.
I mean, women tend to just get better and better and better
and that gap between men and women narrows considerably
as you age up and gets eclipsed as in your case.
I think yeah, I think that's...
I mean like I said, I'm not a scientist,
I don't know the science behind it but I believe like
with a race like Race Across America,
it's 70% mental, 30% physical.
And in this particular one even if you talk to Eric
and I am sorry, I don't know the gentleman
that came in second, but it was a race of attrition,
of who can take the most suffering
because you honestly could not ride as hard as you want to.
It was survival-
It was survival exactly,
so it was a different type of race.
But like you said, I think the gap does get narrower
'cause a lot of women have won,
the transcontinental German lady won the race.
Some ultra running races, a couple of them have won races.
So I think the gap does close as you get
into the longer races where it's not so much
on your strength but on your mental ability
and how much pain you can take.
Yeah, women can take more pain-
I think well maybe yeah.
I think so.
I think you're a living example of that.
Are you gonna do this again?
Oh, absolutely.
I didn't, I mean-
'Cause you didn't meet your time goal.
I did not meet my goal so I remember crossing the line
and I go, oh damn it, I gotta do it again.
I was getting...
I'm just fixated on 10 days.
I just you know...
I know I'm really pushing the envelope,
I'm not a spring chicken but I still feel
that I have the ability to ride it in 10 days.
And what did you learn with this RAAM
that will be instructive in terms of tweaking your training
for the next one?
I have to learn, it's the heat.
I mean honestly, if you take the heat away,
I believe I could've made my goal, I really do.
I felt like I was smarter this time, my crew was smarter,
we were prepared navigational wise,
we made very little error.
Yeah, I think that it's just...
I think just the weather conditions is what handicapped us.
Like I said it wasn't just one section of the race,
it was right across the country.
Yeah.
So when you're done, how long do you then sleep for?
Or is your body just so messed up that you can only sleep
like an hour and then you're up again?
Your body is pretty messed up.
It took me, I'm gonna say almost a week before
I could go into that regular cycle.
'Cause you're in this trauma,
it's like your body's trying to protect you from dying.
And it takes a while before it realizes like,
oh, the heat's off, is there a cra...
And then there's a crash, right?
Yeah.
Well, I mean I think too it's important.
Like, I got on the bike pretty fast
when I felt like I had some pretty serious saddle sores.
But it just spinning just really lights being
is moving the body.
So I don't think you want to cold Turkey it,
I don't think it's good for the body.
You know I think you'll recover faster if you stay...
'Cause you know, you think about all the training leading up
to this race, right.
And just to do nothing, I think that is worse
for you than actually getting back and doing so I did.
I mean because of COVID I had to quarantine
so I did a lot of trainer workouts at home
for the two weeks.
But I think that really helped me recover
and again as I was telling you,
I think it was the body, I couldn't push myself
as hard as I wanted to.
So my muscles weren't particularly sore
as the damage to my skin, my face and whatnot.
Oh my God.
And the other thing is you did this plant-based,
you're a plant-based athlete.
Correct?
Yeah.
How long have you been plant-based?
Well, it's funny, it's been in phases.
I mean, I actually stopped eating meat
when I was a little girl.
I just loved animals so much and you think about it
in my generation, at five years,
I said mom I'm not eating meat anymore.
And I was vegan right into the military.
I was mostly I got call a fruitarian
and I remember in the military they said,
oh, you're gonna get osteoporosis and you're gonna,
you're not gonna do well in this side.
I mean I was the top of my game in the military.
You're like, I'm the one training you.
Yeah.
How to do this.
But it was more the doctor saying that but I think
as I think I told you earlier is that a lot of the soldiers
like the commando soldiers were vegetarians.
Like the military really catered,
you didn't have that in Canada.
I think there was a whole section in the military
and the food room called the food room
where the food is made for the soldiers.
Half the food room is all vegan options you know.
And I was amazed during that time
that a lot of soldiers higher...
Even a lot of the athletes, they were not necessarily
just plant-based but just vegetarians
or didn't eat eggs, dairy or whatnot.
And then I moved back to Canada and on the national team,
the issue was, is I didn't have the food that I needed.
Like when we're in Europe, they fed you.
So what they would give me was white bread,
cheese and whatnot.
So the dietician there said,
you have to start eating a little bit of meat
and whatnot to get your strength back.
And so I did, I flipped back and I started eating meat,
not feeling too great but not feeling too great either
because you can be vegetarian and not healthy
by eating the wrong foods.
And then I remember watching the Game Changer
and I saw Dotsie there and I go, what the hell?
And so I remember, and I called her and I said Dotsie,
thank God I saw you, you know what I mean?
And I just, my dad, you're just watched this documentary.
And I thought what an idiot I am, you know what I mean?
And as soon as I did, everything went up,
my recovery was better, I rode stronger, I rode faster.
I felt great, I stepped better, you know what I mean?
So, yeah.
So it was kinda like in waves.
Sure.
But Game Changers only came out a couple of years ago.
So you only deployed that plant-based diet
in the most recent ramp.
About two and a half years ago, yeah.
This most recent one, correct, yes.
Yeah, yeah.
And you could feel a difference.
Oh, for sure.
I mean I know how I felt back in.
It depends what your options are to eat.
And just going that route.
I mean instantly within the week,
I said, this is how I felt when I was in the military
and you forget about that.
But mind you even when I was eating, I didn't eat beef
or anything, just a little bit of chicken and fish.
I still didn't feel good or didn't feel...
'Cause I do it for humanitarian reasons.
At that time I wasn't thinking about the health-
Right, you'd be doing it irrespective of
how it impacted your athletic performance.
But yeah, I mean, I'm a big believer,
I don't push it on people or whatever.
Yeah, you're low key about it.
Like you're not out on the pulpit.
No, no.
Banging the drum about this.
No.
I mean to each their own,
everybody knows what's good and what's right.
I'm not there to tell you what to do
but I know what works for me and what makes me feel good.
You know so.
Have you met Dotsie?
Oh yeah, we raced together.
Oh you did.
Yeah, yeah.
So you know her from the racing years?
Yeah, yeah, I know her.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah.
She's the best.
Yeah, yeah.
I totally know her year.
It's awesome, yeah.
That's cool.
It's like she slapped me through the TV right?
Yeah.
So it was meant to be.
But I know her.
Yeah.
Wow.
So what is a day in the life of food look like for you
when you're training really hard.
When I'm training really hard?
Well I do a lot of smoothies,
I like to stick to liquids on the bike as much as possible.
You're pretty much liquid during RAAM throughout,
you just can't...
Especially in the heat to be able to keep down-
I couldn't eat anything, no.
And if I could, it's just fruit,
like watermelon is big, grapes are big
like the juicy fruits kind of stuff you know.
What about dates?
Dates, I didn't use dates.
I mean, I use it in training but not so much in the race.
Hammer is my, they have a lot of hammer, vegan bars
and stuff, they have awesome vegan protein powders
or whatever.
I like how you call vegan.
Or vegetarian, vegan, vegan, it's a Canadian thing.
(both laughs)
So yeah I mean-
But in training like walk me through
like the real foods that you're eating.
Well, I mean they would give me wraps,
tofu scramble wraps, avocado was a big one, rice, beans.
But keeping it simple.
Just keep that, they just in little wraps
when giving me from the bike,
like you're doing everything on the bike.
So, just simple light foods.
'Cause again, you don't have a huge appetite,
you just don't.
If you just keep it consistent, a lot of fluids.
Again in that kind of heat,
as you know, it's really difficult to use.
And the training, I mean you're on the bike
like 60 hours a week.
But you live where it gets cold.
How much of that is indoors on a trainer
versus out on the road.
In the winter, it's 100% indoors because I live in Vernon.
So you cannot ride out.
I mean, you can with the snow bike,
I know the big fat tires.
Yeah.
I don't do that.
So, but I'll start...
Like I'll cross train with running,
like you know trail running ice,
it's called crampons or little spikes
on the bottom of your shoes or whatever so, I'll do that
or I'll drive to Vancouver, my parents live there.
You can ride there it's very rainy but you can ride outside.
But I'm gonna say trainer workouts in the winter,
it's probably about 70 to 80% for me.
And how do you deal with just the mental doldrums of that?
That's RAAM.
Like do you watch movies and listen to music or-
Oh sorry no way I don't.
Just a complete deprivation tank?
Don't listen to music, don't look at my phone.
Not your suffering.
Yeah, no television, no nothing
so I don't get that when I race.
Like in Kansas all you see is road for 20 hours
so I guess-
That's another level of discipline
'cause it would be so easy to just set up a laptop
in front of you and watch something while you're doing it.
No, like I remember like even sometimes,
downstairs if somebody turns on the TV,
I almost find it like a distraction.
I just try to-
So where does your mind go?
It just goes to what I'm doing
like I'll replicate a course or a ride or whatever,
like I'll do like a replicated climb.
On K, I'm gonna ride flat here for 20 K or whatever,
they'll climb for two hours and I'll go down
to the flat skin.
So I'll play things in my head
but that's Race Across America,
you just have to be in robot mode
and just keep pedaling looking forward
and don't think about anything else.
Time becomes very fluid and malleable
like when you've been doing that for a while
and you increase your volume,
suddenly what used to feel like forever feels like nothing.
Like an eight hour ride can feel like a two-hour ride
when you acclimated yourself to it.
But it does require that level of discipline.
Well, I mean it's training too.
Like I remember it's funny that you say that,
'cause sometimes like veering the end of my training,
I'd be so I go, yay, I only have to do 10 hours today.
Yeah, it's all perspective. (Rich laughs)
But that's better than 20 hours.
So that's funny that you say that
and like going for a four hour ride is a warmup,
you know what I mean?
So, again like you said, it's in perspective
but for around, that's what you're gonna do
for 9, 10, 11, 12 days.
So, it's better that you training
and you know what that feels like
rather than experiencing that in the race.
Talk to me about how martial arts interplay
with endurance sports like I'm interested in
what you've kind of gleaned from being a martial artist,
a combat, athlete and you know what lessons from that world
are applicable to ultra endurance and vice versa.
Like how do those worlds compliment each other?
Well I think it's discipline and consistency.
Like with combat sports and Taekwondo or whatever
or martial arts, you have to train and practice
'cause it's a skilled sport.
Writing is more, you're just peddling, you know what I mean?
It's a mental thing of but you have to practice
and again pecans.
And even when you're having those days
where you just don't wanna do it, you have to do it.
'Cause you're not always gonna have those great days.
Few and far beyond, you're gonna have those great days.
So I think it's a matter of again of the consistency
and no matter where you are, how you feel
that you gotta do whatever you have to do.
A key difference being,
when you're a combat sports athlete, you have an opponent.
But in endurance, really the opponent is you.
Like, you're not..
There are other people in the race,
but it's kind of irrelevant because it's a contest
between you and yourself.
Exactly.
There's nothing more difficult than kickboxing,
I'll tell you that much.
Exactly what you said because you have more control
when you're doing cycling or whatever, you can stop it
but if you stop when you're fighting someone,
they'll beat you up, you know what I mean?
That you have to be one op on that.
So, I found it way more challenging and way more important
to be on top of your game in that particular sport,
because the objective of that sport is
to knock the other person down.
Sure.
And also if you drop your guard, you can get injured-
In one second.
Like you can just get off your bike,
I mean, maybe you fall asleep on your bike and you tip over.
That's not so good or you crash descending 80 miles an hour
and peel your face off but generally the stakes
are a little bit more dire and higher
in a combat mission of course.
Oh for sure, there is no comparison.
Yeah.
So they're very different in that regard but the discipline,
the attention to detail and precision.
In ultra endurance, you can kinda...
Because it's so long, you're not gonna be perfect.
So precision is less applicable but you have to stay
on top of all those details like saddle sores
and your nutrition schedule and all of that
like there's a rigor to that I think that is demanding
and essential if you're gonna compete to your potential.
But it becomes almost systematic
like you know the routine, you know what...
Like you said, there's way more elements
in ultra endurance racing.
It's not just a matter of doing one thing,
like you said, it's nutrition, it's clothing,
it's your bike, it's everything.
But it becomes almost like second nature.
That's why being consistent with it
and not doing the training even when you don't feel like it
is important and staying on top of your game.
And always pushing harder than you wanna push.
Like I try to train harder than I would in a race.
So the race almost feels easy.
Not just a matter of sitting on your bike
and peddling away mindlessly,
there's a purpose to what you're doing.
And I think for me that's really important,
it means to prepare yourself especially
when you're going after a goal,
like we're going after a 10 day goal.
So I have to be come to that line
in the best shape possible.
And that requires a lot of training, specific training,
being on top of it and consistency.
That posts who, okay, I just wanna finish in 12 days,
that's a whole different ball game.
But what I'm going after is a little bit more intense.
So the precision, organization
and having a good team behind you like my crew has
to be on the same page as me.
People don't realize how important.
Your finish is determined by your crew,
how good your crew is.
Right, it is a team sport in that sense.
It's a total team sport.
And you think about putting nine people together, right.
Oh there's legendary stories-
Oh my God.
Of crews blowing up and leaving-
Oh yeah, we had one.
I mean, you'll see,
I mean, we have a documentary coming out,
you'll see one crew member taking off in the car.
He just took off.
So, I mean it's crazy, the dynamics that go in,
like that's a whole new podcast where you wreck it all.
You would think like we're in an RV or we're in a van,
we're going all the way across the country,
this person's on a bike.
Like, what are we gonna do?
We're gonna crank the tunes, we're gonna kick back,
it's gonna be awesome.
But literally like you're taking bottle drops
like every 15 minutes or whatever
and they have to sleep too.
Were you rotating crew members between multiple vehicles.
No, we had two sets of crew members, three and three.
So they do 12 hour shifts,
you had a day shift and then a night shift. Right.
So at least it gives them a bit of time too
but still there's lots fill up the gas,
think of the navigation they have to eat too.
To keep me prepared, know about the terrain,
know about who's, where, or whatever,
there's a lot of things going on,
you can ask any crew member that those 12 hours just fly by.
And it's not like they get 12 hours off.
It's not no such a case-
Are they Israeli commandos?
Sorry.
(Leah laughs)
No.
They should be, they could be at the end of that.
They'd be like Johnny on the spot.
I totally agree, yeah.
Yeah.
I think Yuri Roebuck had, wasn't he like a Slovenian army
or something like that and he had like his whole crew
were military guys and they had like military vehicles
and he had like speakers on the crew vehicle
that would broadcast like military anthems
in the middle of the night.
There's all these weird stories about-
Maybe I should try it.
I'll try that next year.
Well, you don't like any music,
right?
No I don't.
Are you allowed to wear earbuds
or you can't do any of that.
No, just earbuds to your car and then only one.
And no crew member can actually like touch you,
right.
No.
And you can't touch the crew V, how does that work?
I mean, I can't hold on to the car but let's say like,
when I'm getting off the bike,
say I'd take a bathroom break and I'm clipping in,
he can give me a push or he
or she can just push me off but no contact.
'Cause there was a thing when the...
In the last mile when you got handed the running shoes
like, wasn't it...
No, the running shoes I was off the bike.
They just, I was already, I was on the grass
and then I...
'Cause you can't do that on the bikes.
But they can touch the bike, like there's all this...
I don't know exactly what the rules are
but I know it's very strange.
They can assist you like when you're starting
'cause you know you're very wobbly.
They give you a look at how...
'Cause of the momentum on the bike,
you kinda get used to that.
But once you get off the bike, you'll look like
a drunk person so they can kinda veer you on,
stabilize you, give you a little push,
but it's not like they can push you for half a mile
or something like that.
So, you wanna be realistic on to what
but for safety reasons,
they're allowed to assist you that way.
But when you're on the bike and you're riding,
they can't touch you.
And your geotag the whole time so the organizers know
where every competitor is.
Absolutely.
So when you run into a scenario like there's construction
or the bridge's washed out or something like that,
like how do you figure out
how to proceed without getting disqualified?
Well, for example we were in the lead coming
to Kansas and the bridge was washed out, it's like you said.
So we call headquarters.
They give me a time credit for them to figure it out.
They look on route and they give me a detour.
And don't forget there are officials on route.
And normally but there wasn't one ahead,
far enough ahead of us to catch that obstruction.
So then they give you a reroute on that.
So that happens many times, that's why you're
in constant communication with headquarters.
Talk to me about the documentary going on.
I watched the trailer.
Did you watch it yeah-
It's exciting.
Well the documentary is just basically...
It's based on the book, it's gonna...
It follows me through round-
You're rewriting the book right now, aren't you?
Yes we are, we're updating the book to say,
we're gonna have a new name, new cover,
it's out a few more chapters,
is freshen it up a little bit.
There a lot more to the story.
There is, yeah.
Well, I mean we'd need multiple books
to kinda squish it a little bit.
Yeah and then the documentary they started filming
in 2019, 2018 actually.
And kinda go back a little bit on my past and leading...
There's like footage of you competing
as a kickboxer, right?
Like just like footage of you as a kid.
Correct yeah.
Yes, there's...
Yeah, you'll see lots of old footage, it's funny.
So what's the plan with the doc?
Well, right now we're just...
Actually we just had a screening last night.
Oh you did?
Yeah, so we're...
'Cause the producer and director actually lives in LA
so this is perfect.
So yeah, we had a screening,
it still needs to get a little bit, some graphics done,
some coloring, some music, and then we're hoping
for next year, summer.
And what's your training look like right now?
Well, I just finished my last week prior to coming to LA.
So I'll take about like three or four weeks,
When I say off, I'll just cross train.
I just do keep with the core work and then do some running
and hiking and hanging out with my dogs and family
and do some normal things you know.
Yeah.
And then like occasionally flip a house.
Maybe, yeah.
(both laughs)
If I see something, perhaps.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well to round this out,
I mean I think it would be helpful for people
who are listening or watching
who perhaps have difficulty kind of connecting
with the specifics of your story
because your superhuman and the things that you do,
but the principles I think are applicable to anyone.
So for that person who feels a little bit stuck
or is struggling with their...
Maybe it's their weight or their fitness
or they're just looking to kind of mix up their life
a little bit and unstick themselves
from whatever situation they're in,
you as this person who's thought deeply
about a lot of this stuff and speaks to public groups
about this like how do you trigger that person
to think differently about their life
and perhaps start blazing a new trajectory?
I think too sometimes hearing other people's stories
of what other people have gone through,
helps you kind of regroup and think about your own self.
You know what? If she can do it or he can do it,
and I'm honestly not that special,
it's just something that I really wanted to do
and have a passion for.
And I think that, I think we idle too much,
I think when we're faced with fear,
there's this instinct of fight or flight
but I think many of us, we freeze, we don't know what to do.
And I think it's because
we just placed too much limitations on ourselves.
And we always focus on that one bad thing
that could happen opposed to all the great things
that could happen.
And I think that's what handicaps us.
And I just think my motto is...
It's not how many times you fall,
it's how many times you can get back up
and not to sit there and wait for things to happen.
Life's too short, you can't sit there
and wait for things to happen 'cause nothing will happen.
It's a matter of you taking the responsibility,
stepping forward and make your life
whatever you want it to be 'cause you know,
possibilities are endless.
Yeah.
I think that's really powerful and helpful.
I mean when I think about you and what you've done
and your story, I mean your super power really
is this refusal to quit.
And you have talents, like you're naturally very athletic,
but you weren't born with extraordinary gifts
like Michael Phelps' feet or something like that.
Like you've put yourself in difficult positions
and you've worked your ass off to succeed
and you've had obstacles along the way.
But you understand that the talent deficit gap gets narrowed
by dent of your ability and determination
to outwork everybody else,
like it's a work ethic thing to do.
Well, I mean that's what I'm saying is you don't have
to be gifted in whenever you choose to do.
'Cause there's a gift all of us have,
it's called the gift of work like you just said, right.
It's a matter of utilizing that
'cause I wasn't gifted as a cyclist,
I'm not gifted as a cyclist.
And I knew I had to work-
You spent nine years trying to-
Well, that's what I mean
but I worked my butt off to get there.
And sometimes you do, you have to work harder than your...
The person behind you and beside you or whatever.
And that's the reality of making things happen
but it doesn't mean you can't make it happen.
'Cause everyone has something that lights their fire.
And it might not come easy but whatever you choose to do,
you have to make it to whatever your finish line is.
Even if it's not the outcome that you want,
if not as fast as you wanna get there.
Is your goal is just to get there no matter what it takes.
I think that's a good place to put a pin in it for now.
All right, awesome.
That was super fun talking to you,
how do you feel?
Thank you.
Feel good, thanks for having me, yes thank you.
You look all happy and fired up so that's good.
Cool, well, until the documentary comes out
and until the new edition of the book comes out,
people can find your book No Limits on Amazon.
All the places or on your website, which is your name.
Where are the places that you wanna direct people
who wanna learn more about you?
I think just that's Facebook-
Leahgoldstein.com.
Yeah.
It's RAAM, yeah.
Your accounts on social media are @LeahNoLimits?
Yes.
Yeah, cool.
L-E-A-H.
Correct, yes.
All right, cool.
Well, keep me posted if there's anything I can do
to help around the documentary
or just help get the word out about your story.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
I'm at your service.
Yeah, I really do...
I mean, it's really powerful,
the things that you have done are unbelievable
and the lessons behind them I think
are even more instructive and I just want more people
to be aware of your journey.
So it was a delight to talk to you.
Thanks so much.
Do you have a copy of the book?
I don't.
Can I give you one?
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course, cool.
I'll give you a few books too.
Awesome, that'd be great,
thank you.
That'd be cool.
And we'll talk again soon, thanks.
Yeah, thanks so much, I appreciate.
Awesome, yeah.
(Leah laughs)
(upbeat music)